[Music]
okay everybody it is a glorious day
because i am with madison as heisman aka
lennon aka allison aka maddie ice she's
back on the show
she's promoting this time i know what
you did last summer how you doing today
madison oh good how are you it's always
good to see your face
yes i'm excited to see you uh now we
both have plain backgrounds we're
looking very professional today it's
very different from last time but
i'm excited to talk to you about this
show i was so hyped for you to be
starring in this and blew me away i
didn't even realize you were playing
twins here so
is it double the work playing two
characters and can you use this when
contract talk comes around
um i'll skip that question but um
it is it's double everything so it's
double memorizing
double the hours
really it's it's double everything but
i had an amazing acting double and
honestly and she had to do it all too so
like she worked hard and did such a good
job and also you know our directors our
sarah is amazing um because it's
definitely i didn't realize how
technical playing twins would be and
there's a lot that comes to play even
like having the whole special effects on
board when you're just having a normal
dialogue scene like they were always
there so it was very interesting
so that's interesting too because you
just mentioned your acting double so
your scene partner that's on the other
side of you when you're doing these
scenes is there always a scene partner
though or there's sometimes you're
talking to nobody
usually there's always a scene partner
also because technically to make sure
you're looking in the same height
small things like that though there are
a couple scenes
where zeke
we're both twins were in a scene
together with zeke and he wanted me to
play both so i think there was i was
literally like behind the camera like
turning my head and then like turning
back and i'm like this is so silly like
if people saw what we were doing they
think this is ridiculous but it worked
yeah and i mean it totally works but
when you see yourself on screen and you
see
you know yourself in twin form do you
get in your head seeing both
performances and like comparing them
like is that like a surreal experience
well i mean i feel like that in just
normal performances you know like i as
some people are really good at watching
themselves some people less so much i'm
somewhere in the middle
so seeing two of me definitely
like you kind i feel like i have to go
back and watch it twice because you kind
of just like leave the planet for a
second you're like my brain can't
compute what's happening
so
it was interesting but um but i'm proud
of it i love them both equally so much
no you should be proud of it it's such a
great performance and really shows off
your skill and
i'm wondering too at the end of the day
i think a lot of people are going to ask
are you more having fun playing allison
here or lennon what what at the end of
the day are you most always excited to
play definitely the most fun was lennon
because she's pretty freaking crazy um
and just like kind of anything goes with
her so like always had a fun time though
i did i really i fell in love with
allison and just her poor little heart
so i do
things i like about them differently
both fun equally fun and it was nice to
get a break from one i will say that
switch it up no
yeah i like that and i mean this is
exciting times for you you've been in
the conjuring universe jumanji you've
been on disney we talked about fear of
rain last time and now you're in this
big franchise it's gonna have the y
audience on amazon are you ready to blow
up now like i feel like you're gonna go
into that next level are you prepared
emotionally i expect nothing i i love
what i do i love to work i love to play
crazy characters and crazy shows and
that will always be the fundamental but
i do i hope i hope people really do love
it and if because we worked really hard
on it and we personally really love it
so
if people like it great we'll see you
know like you never know
there you go she's humble with this
success and fame which is the best way
to go everybody check out i know what
you did last summer it is out now the
twin roll got the emmy for ruffalo let's
get the campaign going for madison here
madison have a great day and i hope to
have the hat trick one day and talk to
you again
good to see you have a good one